We have to go back,
Marty, back to the past.
I mean one that persists.
>> Hold it.
Let's pause for a second and
talk about what persistence and
persisting data actually means.
[SOUND]
>> Persistence is saving data to a place
where it can be re-accessed and
retrieved upon restart of the device or
app.
This can mean nonvolatile memory on your
device or saving data to remote servers.
Persistence is necessary for any app
that wants to store data long term.
That is longer than a life
cycle that running app and
keep it available to the user.
In this course we Fernando, me and
you will go over how persistence works,
why it's needed,
what options are available for
creating persistent iOS apps and
what the most important ones are.
We'll also add simple persistence
to a recording app, and
work in a completely new app to
level up our persistence skills.
You'll see a lot of Eden at the start
and more of me Fernando later on.
As course developers here at Udacity
we are here to guide you through
the learning process of
iOS app persistence.
We'll start with NS user defaults.
One of the available options for
persistence.
Then in lesson two we'll discuss
the iOS file system and sandboxing.
In lesson three, we'll move on to our
second and most important option for
persistence, core data.
Where we'll talk about pieces
of the core data stack,
how to create a data model and how to
make objects from that data model.
Lesson four will finish implementing
core data, and see how it
actually persists our changes, will see
what happens behind the scenes, and
most importantly, what core data
provides beyond persistence.
We'll also learn how to display
core data objects in tables, and
collection views.
And in lesson five will dive deeper,
and find out how to search and
filter objects.
And how to migrate our data model,
which is vital to know before
uploading an app to the App Store.
So let's get started by finding out
how the Doc plans to save Marty's
algorithm by using NS user defaults.